My first step was to attend a
lecture
by a controversial author.
I was clearly entering a world
of fear, obsession,
and probably madness.
(man)
Airplane mode is a joke.
It is a dangerous time
because the Illuminati is
coming up with various methods
to bring about
the Fourth Reich.
Controlling the weather,
detonating underwater nukes
to cause tsunamis.
(Forrest voice-over)
Listening to this man
ascribe all the word's tragedies
to a shadowy
underground network,
I began to grasp the appeal
of believing in conspiracies.
Perhaps it would be nice
to think that life's misfortunes
aren't simply random,
but are instead the work
of a villain who can be
smoked out and defeated.
Which brings us
to the Interdimensional Bigfoot.
(Forrest)
I understand better than anyone
that the randomness
of life can be scary.
Thanks to this television show,
my entire existence
is given over to random chance.
Gina, from Toluca Lake
has a question.
What would it be
like to kill a person?
What's it
like to be a cult leader?
What's it like
to be kicked in the balls?
And when you really
think about it,
things
haven't always gone so well.
[gunfire]
Ah!
I am infested with sea lice!
[screaming]
[gagging]
I'm having a heart attack,
you guys.
Ow!
[screaming]
Maybe it would feel
better to believe
that the difficult experiences
I've had on this show
were not the product
of pure blind, random chance.
Is there any reason
to think that something else
might be going on?
Well, let's find out.
Mm-hmm.